chat auf jeden fall ganz hoch in der
video beschreiben um den lenker haben da
ist doch ein richtig geiles fehlt mir
hey leute was glaubt willkommen beim
neuen video und zwar bin ich ja letztens
auf die idee gekommen mir meine haare zu
färben habe ich auch gemacht wie man
sieht also eigentlich sollten das jetzt
nur so 123 strähnen seien die alt blond
sind wird dann irgendwie nix draus also
die sind jetzt jemand sieht so fast
überall blond auf jeden fall war mir
klar dass ich nur positive resonanzen
darauf fallen sagt man dass er das sagt
man so und dass das jetzt jeder bisschen
abfahrt war eigentlich klar allerdings
hat sich das volle maß gehalten so was
die kommentare einem klar einige meinen
das sieht nicht so gut aus eine gemeinde
theres steht dir voll gut einige meinen
auch also dieser kommentar sich wirklich
den gab's so und zwar war das einmal
folgender kommentar und zwar ob ich
jetzt schwul geworden wäre weil ich mir
meine haare blond gefärbt haben oder ob
ich jetzt schwul geworden wäre weil ich
aussehe wie justin bieber weil ich mir
meine haare blond gefärbt hat also
eigentlich beides mal das gleiche so
hanne aber ja okay leute ich kann es
euch jetzt auch sagen ja ich bin schwul
ich stehe auf looki was laberst du junge
sorry aber so was passiert wenn man sich
seine haare blond färben junge sitzt
mich verarschen
nein er ja vorher als meine haare noch
dunkel war war das ihr auch noch nicht
so jetzt mal spaß sondern heute auch
wenn es euch nicht vorstellen könnt
alles ist nicht schwul nein sicher okay
leute deinen spaß also ich denke ich
dass sie das jetzt geglaubt denkt auch
nicht hätte irgendwas gegen schwule oder
so aber ich wollte jetzt nur einmal so
kurz das ist doch total dumm nur weil
ich meine haare gefärbt hat stehe ich
jetzt nicht mehr auf mädchen oder wie
alles klar ja ob jetzt habe ich auch die
kommentare unter alex video gesehen da
wo er sich die haare gefärbt und wir
setzen uns darüber unterhalten wie genau
man heutzutage wenig aufpassen muss über
veränderungen an sich selbst weil es
kann halt heutzutage einfach super
einfach passieren dass irgend wie heute
welche verrückten sachen
reininterpretiert nein ganz ehrlich bin
wirklich traurig dass alex menschen
wegen seiner haarfarbe als schwul
betiteln ich mal gesagt überhaupt gar
nichts aus ich finde es einfach schade
und traurig und so was so was brauchen
wir nicht vor allem auf youtube und ganz
ehrlich alexander erhart sehen ziemlich
cool aus und ich finde es gut dass es
gemacht das habe ich auch schon private
sagt küsschen
ja aber ohne scheiß sollte das wirklich
genauso ich mein was haben bitte blonde
haare mit schwulsein zu tun ist jetzt
jeder der von natur aus blonde haare
schwul oder wie hey alter mann ich
verstehe es manchmal nicht manchmal
verstehe ich einige okay das sind jetzt
natürlich nur 0,02 prozent von euch aber
ich zeig euch nicht was ist in eurem
kopf falsch gelaufen sagt mir leitet
down in the comments please ja heute ich
glaube dieses videos jetzt etwas kürzer
geraten ansonsten auf lukas channel ist
doch nichts nämlich ein zweiter teil
aber dass auch ein video von mir und mit
ihm all das ganz unten nach ganz oben in
der video beschreibung verlinkt das auf
jeden fall ab abonniert luki auch
persönlich sehr freuen
ansonsten mich von dir natürlich auch
abonieren instagram zettel war es
eingeblendet hier oben links kommen wir
dann halt zudem hier ist müll wer ist
auch egal welches gar nix ich wünsche
euch noch einen schönen sonntag ich
hoffe dass wir deutlich gefallen können
gern doch nach oben gehen
jack black eyed peas